et figurez vous qu'à force d'être envahi
par les images de sexe des débats sur le
sec et ses bas les jeunes les pauvres
n'éprouverait plus aucun désir c'est
fini il n'y a plus rien c'est ce que
nous explique je t'aime et ses du sexe
on en mange à toutes les sauces dans la
littérature sur les écrans dans les jeux
vidéo dans les médias dans la mode même
dans la politique mais à l'heure où le
sexe est tout-puissant certains résiste
à l'envahisseur la moitié des 20 24 ans
n'aurait pas eu de relations sexuelles
l'année passée se mettre à la diète
c'est presque la nouvelle révolution
sexuelle de la jeunesse faut dire que
certains accusent le sexe d'avoir tué
l'amour mais pour certains spécialistes
si les jeunes font la grève du sexe ce
n'est pas par esprit de rébellion mais
c'est surtout à cause d'internet et des
applications de rencontres géolocaliser
connectés en permanence la jeunesse
ferait passer sous smartphone avant le
sexe hulu se satisferait d'une vie
sexuelle virtuelle sur internet au
royaume des plaisirs en solitaire alors
qu'est ce que vous en pensez de cette
petite baisse de désir chez ces jeunes
gens parce qu'il y aurait trop de sexe
partout alors que par exemple ici on
n'en parle jamais jamais jamais par
exemple
non mais qu'est ce que vous en pensez et
c'est évidemment c'est à moi que ça
s'adresse parce que mon regard a croisé
le vôtre réaliser mais je vais vous
surprendre je vais vous répondre parce
que je sais que vous attendez tous à ce
que je disais oui l'amour à perdre
l'amour le sexe appelle le sexe oui eh
bien figurez-vous que pas du tout or ce
domaine qu'est ce qui vous a la rivalité
de fièvre toux truc qui m'a pas la
qualité valérie aarhus que la quantité
que tu vas voir les jeux l'audi et je
n'en mets rarement les 2 par armand
l'état chez moi et si tu fais ce que je
fais c'est à dire que il faut puisque
les fenêtres alors il faut évidemment
des périodes de sexe ensuite marqué un
petit temps de pause une sorte de
jachère pardonnez moi à votre échelle à
dire quoi 30 minutes 40 chez vous un
jour plusieurs jours il faut les limites
frustré le partenaire à d'accord que tak
le désir reviennent et tout d'un coup la
can et oran pas me tout le monde
mécaniquement sera en place d'accords
c'est prouver par des études par des
scientifiques je me disais tiens je
crois que j'ai raison mais oui parce que
ça a été confirmé par des études
américaines suédoise française tout ce
que vous voulez quand mais là je cherche
à chasser par les vagues trop de sait
combien de sur le sexe inhibiteurs de
désir d'accord car le mot parce que
c'est
ça veut dire combien de temps la pause
parce que voilà il faut être précis une
semaine mais je vais ma pauvre caroline
je vais je être frustré parce que je
vais t'expliquer que chez les mecs plus
tu fais l'amour plus tu as envie de
faire l'amour
donc j'ai pensé à toi d'ailleurs ce
moment tu prend énormément de risques
je sais ce que tu as raison maintenant
on l'attendait peut-être qu elle éponge
hr l'on sait pas non mais ou alors elle
s'est construit un personnage parce que
pour nous carrossée quand même
l'expression de la sexualité ne pas
avoir de sexe ça veut pas dire ne pas
s'aimer ne pas faire la moue autres et
amplis à sec cela tu parle pas d'amour
mais moi les mecs le sexe plus pratique
et plus tu as envie de prendre les quais
oui mais ça c'est trop visiblement là on
a compris
en tout cas beaucoup donc boris son mari
va être très content de savoir qu'ils
peuvent pas faire et la qualité et la
quantité c'est génial et en plus c'est
vrai quand d'hypocrites que la rochelle
on s'en sort à tous les soirs galles là
vous nous cachez des mémés attendait
c'est comme chez vous n'avez et mon chat
c'est bien aujourd'hui
[Applaudissements]
aujourd'hui le seul loisir qu'ont acquis
gratuit enfin sauf pour thibaut mai
très bien jacques thibaud ce qu'est ce
qui est expliqué c'est le phénomène de
jachère ça m'a perturbé demain sur la
jachère vous êtes d'accord et non celle
qui en parlent le plus qui auront fait
le moins en fait
ah oui il était déçu là je il ya un
mythe qui tombe on sait d'après son et
lumière on s'est mal compris mais non
c'est pas mal compris en cause de faire
une pause c'est important moi je pense
au couple de français oui à tous les
couples c'est pour ça je donne un
conseil
d'accord j'ai vraiment à des études
scientifiques qui ont été faites il faut
qui fit se calmer sur la qualité sur la
quantité et privilégier la qualité voilà
quand on écoute et on vient du coup on
va retourner au caire yes 4,5 dans les
médias on a posé la question à nos
téléspectateurs est ce que vous
confirmez ou absolument pas confirmé
pour 46% mais absolument pas pour 54%
petit coquin ok très bien on a compris